hi everyone and thanks for joining us
today
today we're going to talk about running
amthos from bad matter at the edge with
major league baseball
my name is omar abdirazic i'm a product
manager at google cloud as part of the
anthos theme and i'm here with my friend
chris amy from major league baseball
hi amir thanks for having me on today
now i run the team at mlb that covers
off all the infrastructure
for our fan facing services which run on
entos and a google cloud
i look forward to showing you what we've
got to offer
awesome thank you chris so the first
question is
uh why the edge and why are we talking
about the edge so
customers are demanding a more connected
experience and this is happening across
different sectors
whether it is three-tier connected
factories healthcare and even gaming
what this means is enterprises are
need to deploy applications in many
places whether from the left you're
looking for something at the very far
edge
hundreds of thousands of sites very low
latency very small footprint
and some of the use cases of that is
real-time control industrial security
real time or you got something like the
near edge where you have
less sides probably less sensitively on
the latency
and you're looking at something like
video and image analysis and processing
or you go more to looking at traditional
data center core or cloud
and the challenge is how do you deploy
across all of these
and this is hard because as you're
looking to deploy across all of these
applications
you're looking at migrating applications
the
developers are deploying applications
differently
every cloud or every site is different
you need to deploy the application
multiple times you can move everything
to every location so
it is just hard to uh trying to manage
across all of these infrastructure
and the good news is there is actually a
perfect storm of opportunity about some
of the technologies happening in the
market that have been happening over the
last couple of months
so the first one of course is 5g uh
there's a lot of connectivity options
that are out there that is improving
connectivity
latency and bandwidth for those edge
scenarios
the second one is containers and you
have a portable application form factor
that allows you to deploy across
different environments
with ease and finally there is the open
source
the continuous innovation with novender
lock-in led by kubernetes and many other
technologies that are out there in the
markets
so this presents a great opportunity to
use all of these
new innovations and leverage your
existing data and deliver your
applications to what you want
so we're going to have a little bit of
how can emphasis help you with this
problem
so emphasis is our platform for
application modernization
it allows you to run on google cloud
on-premise on other cloud providers or
at the edge
and the idea is anthos gives you manage
operation the service management part
and the marketplace and commerce
so that you can even add more
applications from third party providers
and anthony's gives you multiple
deployment options
from cloud platform as we discussed
vsphere
aws you can even bring your own
kubernetes
or you can deploy it on bad metal edge
scenarios and azure
that is coming soon so across all of
these options emphasis provide you the
deployment flexibility
to deploy application anywhere and have
the consistency
of your operational workflow and your
developer workflow
so we're going to talk a little about
enthus on bare metal technical overview
which is our newest offering that we
announced recently
so the idea for anthros on bad metal is
you can run anthos on a customer
provided operating system
in this scenario you can install amthos
where the customer deploys and manages
the os lifecycle
you have preflight checks to validate
the minimum system requirements
and then you have an idiom protein and
declarative installer for all adverse
components
where you can run it from a compute
capacity you can deploy this on a
physical or a virtual infrastructure
and we expect most of our customers to
run this on physical server
but running on your choice of visual
infrastructure is also possible
uh we intend to support rails and to us
in ubuntu
and from a networking standpoint l3
connectivity between the nodes is
required and we need l2 between the low
balancing nodes
but google provides an overlay
networking l4 and l7 load balancing
from a storage uh you can integrate with
your
storage infrastructure using csi upgrade
will be in place and from an
observability standpoint of course we
have out of the box stack driver or now
cloud monitoring metrics and logs
or you can integrate with the customer
provided observable tool if you want
we're also considering vm lifecycle
options uh with technologies like
cubevert and many others
so this provides you a very flexible
stack where you can employ a new
existing infrastructure
and easy run application using amphos
so in terms of managing anthros at the
edge some of the technologies that we
are and the capabilities that we have
makes it very easy
to do so so we're going to cover some of
those so the first one
is the standardized architecture again
you have the flexibility to deploy on
vmware
deploy on your favorite operating system
so
this gives you tremendous flexibility to
deploy where you are
and not have to retrofit your existing
infrastructure
in fact you can leverage your existing
infrastructure to meet your current
and needs and you can even modernize it
in place without impacting the apps
so that's the first uh piece of the uh
application and more organization
managing there
the second is managing the entire fleet
again
one of the challenges that i've seen a
lot of customers is they have thousands
of stores
thousands of locations so managing
across all of these locations
is very hard and having a cloud based
monitoring solution and management
solution helps you there
so one of the technologies is the single
pane of glass
to have for your clusters and workloads
you can manage the cluster from a single
cloud-based work consoles
you have visibility for your entire
fleet no matter where they are
and you can deploy workflows from a
private registry or from a gcp
marketplace
all of this from a console or a
centralized api
through google cloud so this gives you a
great flexibility and
single point to manage and deploy all
your cluster
the second part of centralized login and
monitoring as you
look across all of these locations you
need to understand what's up what's not
you need to diagnose
sending a technician can sometimes be a
very costly and very time consuming
and have an impact to the business if
you have a store that is down
centralized login and monitoring helps
you with that by
aligning all of the data and pushing it
to stackdriver or now cloud monitoring
and then you can see what's happening
error rates performance
you can even manage the life cycle of
those locations
and define slo and monitoring for your
sre codes and signals
so that's from from operations and then
that gives you kind of the fleet wide
policy management again
to do this from a cube ctl you can also
use
get ops i so from a programmatic kind of
sre kind of standpoint you can use
devops technologies you can have your
single team deploy
for example as a canonical version of
the app one place
and it gets replicated across all of
your stores
in a matter of seconds so that also
gives you a lot of flexibility of how to
deploy
apps across the fleet
so we want to talk about edge deployment
models here
and one of the interesting innovations
that we are introducing to the market as
google is
as a customer you don't have to manage
or deploy all the apps it gives you
different options to do so
so the first part is worth mentioning is
google's global network and this is
something that is very unique to google
not just by our data centers but our
connectivity to region pops and networks
that you've used over the years
for search for youtube for stadium
gaming
so these are a combination of cdn edge
point presence dedicated interconnect
and even cloud regions that gives you a
lot of flexibility in that
so from that you have 24 regions we have
144 edge pops and thousands of edge
nodes
in telecom networks but that's the part
that we are starting to have innovation
for it as you integrate with existing
telecom partners
that gives you a lot of options to
expand our network even further
in this partnership and gives you even
closer points of presence
across the globe so this gives us a
flexible operation model
for the edge so we have three options
that will make your life a lot easier as
a customer to deploy the edge
the first one is a google manage edge in
this case you are
using leveraging google's capability
google's infrastructure
for example like edge caching and
service nodes
and using edge point of presence on
google cloud
either coarsely regional zones or edge
regions and loans
so that's the first option the second
option is telco edge
leveraging our existing partnership with
the telcos
and using their small central office
presence and large center office
presence
to deploy this for example so you don't
even have to have it on the store
you can have uh using a combination 5g
and then have your equipment or actually
the telcos equipment
running your application this gives you
the ability to
deploy for example next to your store so
you don't have to have the presence in
the store itself
but actually have something that is very
close and very connected
and finally of course the customer apps
this classical customer edge scenario
where you are deploying on your existing
branch office or your existing kind of
retail location
and that gives you uh the traditional
presence that you
have but also gives you another option
so between the three options
that gives you a lot of flexibility on
designing your own infrastructure
to meet your needs and the appropriate
operational model for your business
for a sample edge architecture and how
the edge is evolving
this is for example a real-time
inventory management and analytics
architecture
so if you build this architecture on
just on a
cloud-only kind of setup this is how it
would look like when you have the
point-of-sale inventory and rfid systems
in the store
but then you have a lot of capabilities
in a cloud provider like google cloud
platform
using technologies like cloud pops up
aggregation analytics
and uh video apis but we also have in
this what emcos gives you is a new
architecture where you can move in some
of those capabilities
to in-store again to make it closer to
where you are
so that you can leverage your platform
of your choice on the services that you
need
but still have the latency and the
sensitivity so again flexibility in the
architecture of how you build your
applications
gives you a lot of options on how you
want to run your business
so in terms of innovation our goal is to
help you with our industry-specific
solution from retail healthcare
financial services media and telco
manufacturing and public sectors across
all of these there are many solutions
that are built out there
best practices and expertise within
google cloud that we can leverage and
help you to build your own indus
specific solution
so next i would like to introduce a use
case of using anthony's at the edge
with major league baseball thanks amir
thanks for having me here
so i thought what better way to start
this whole section of the presentation
off then
let's go through what an actual end user
experience is like
so what we're seeing here is a product
that we call game day you know you go to
mlb.com you click on a game you can see
a sort of virtual experience in a game
here and what we're seeing is
play-by-play data you're seeing pictures
and how the pictures were thrown
what the velocity was where they were in
the strike zone
then we get into like what actual plays
happen you know did a
did a run a steal was there a pick off
attempt was there a home run hit
and even that we you know we're loading
videos of you know
key parts of the game straight into the
feed
and so how does this all come together
we start off with
our new stack cast tracking system that
we have for 2020.
this is a completely new system that
we've developed and deployed
and uses machine vision with a whole
stack of cameras that you know pick up
velocity you know spin rate of the ball
where players are what their poses are
and you know what's happening in the
game
so what we're seeing here is a picture
from the new york yankees this is
a video that we took last year um
of them actually throwing you can see
how the ball you know we dig up the
trajectory we
can you know put it back in time to work
out where it came from and where it's
going to be going through
so how does this all work well as you
know in baseball it all starts with
picture
throw on a pitch so we kick it off we
have an on-field play that happens you
know there's someone in the stadium
or a remote who clicks for the start of
the play then they complete the play
once it's finished um our tracking
system is going to absorb all the data
and all the events
that are happening you know throughout
that play we aggregate it
and we process it in stadium on ethos so
we collect all of that data
we process it we set up a play and then
we ship it up to google cloud
or potentially in stadium if we have
other subscribers that need
that information you know for low
latency reasons in stadium
so what's where do we come from what do
we do so
you know in 2019 we had an aging
hardware stack
in stadium uh you know you can see that
on the right that's what
the end result looks like but we had
this aging hardware
we bring a new tracking uh solution
coming in
um and we needed a way to simplify
modernize
and bring consistency to our on-premise
or in-stadium environment
to know to what we run in the cloud
and you know we had to have something
that would run there be stable
and enable the throughput and the
latency requirements that we have
in stadium
so what does our environment look like
no last year we basically had no
one virtual machine for every
application we ran in the stadium
it had some local storage attached to it
we packaged our apps
you know with rpms you know we had no
real
automatic failover you know we had to
run two copies of everything because
if we lost one we had no way to like
automatically stand it up and run it on
a second location or anything else
and you know if we had a burst in the
stadium we had to process a whole lot of
data you know potentially we were going
to
resend a whole lot of data from a game
that happened in the past and we want to
get it
processed really quickly we had no way
to flexibly
scale up scale down as we need it so
we come into 2020 what do we do uh we
took anthos on-prem you know running on
top of vmware
uh we made the decision that we saw
anthos as this you know standardization
for containers
for all of our applications regardless
of where we ran them whether that's
in google cloud whether it's on-prem or
even in our stadiums
we had this key requirement for
automatic failover
for our processing or worker nodes and
we needed our applications to
horizontally scale
in the stadium just like they would
scale you know if we're running on gk in
the cloud
so our architecture you know it's
probably a little bit different from
your standard
entos on-prem architecture we have an
admin workstation that runs
inside gcp in the cloud and then for
every ballpark of you know we've got two
here displayed you know the rockies
and the marlins no we don't have uh
shared storage in the park we basically
have two processing nodes
uh that we run you know they run vmware
uh and then on top of that they have you
know local storage
and we run the seesaw load balancer
setup uh for each cluster so we have
each node
it's its own cluster it has their own
admin cluster the control planes etc
and then inside that actual you know
physical hardware machine
we have the various worker nodes we need
in our case we run
you know three different worker nodes
so what's our end user interaction you
know we do all this processing in
stadium on anthos
where does data go uh we'll ship it to
in-standing experiences so
that could be up on the scoreboard
you'll see you know you see the the
score change or
you see a pitch speed or what type of
pitch it was
you know we offloaded to our broadcast
partners like watching on tv and you
know you see that
the pitch trajectory or where the home
run was here etc
um we also then take that data and we
ship it up to google cloud
where you get experience from our
digital properties and products that's
what we started
this whole session off with was game day
which is one of those digital properties
or products we also do advanced data
analytics on all this
and we do ai and ml to work out what's
going to be the new metric that we're
going to see come at a baseball in
2020 or 2021
so where do we go to from here um you
know i covered off just before
you know what we do right now on the web
what we got loaded up here is you know a
a rendering of an actual play that
occurred you know
virtually you know it's concepts around
what could we do with this data
um that we haven't ever thought of and
this is where we see antholos as a key
for our go forward with all of our data
that we're shipping from the park
so with that i'd like to throw back to
amira uh really great to have to be here
today and
really excited to see what anthos can
offer thank you very much chris that was
a very
cool use case and as you have seen it
demonstrated the power of anthill's
mlb team had a virtualized
infrastructure at the edge
they deploy it it's the same
infrastructure that they deploy on the
cloud
and then the same infrastructure as they
migrate to bare metal
so our goal with anthos is to bring the
same level of flexibility
of and the power of google cloud to the
edge with an open application platform
flexible deployment option and a strong
ecosystem
so uh i encourage you all to try anthos
on gcp
you can see this link here the link has
a lot of tutorials a lot to demonstrate
and try a lot of the capabilities of
anthos
and um at the end i just want to thank
you all for giving us the time today we
know it's a crazy world out there
so we really appreciate you taking the
time to learn about our technologies and
product
and we look forward to partner and work
with you thank you
you